ouais le Old School remue encore les
foules rap grand-père mais pas pépère
pasil les sugar the sugar gang DEP
rappers del light ils sont plus remix
que prolix mais si l'himne du RIM ne
prend du bide il prend pas une
[Musique]
rigue
of now what you hear is
test and Me The GRP and my friends are
to try to move your feet see I am m and
I like to say hello to the black to the
white the red and the brown the purple
and yellow but first I gotangang the to
the B say up jump the B
theang don't stop ro make
your
[Musique]
hi you heard my but I brought two
friends and next m man come sing that S
it out
C you see I go
by I'll tell you
why and
and got more
[Musique]
ento
take got i play
betall C
moreoney but I wouldn't give a su from
the ro i made it againbody
go
what do
[Musique]
to if
girl then you
[Musique]
take
my
[Musique]
alling shot m for the now I'm not as as
the of the G but to
[Musique]
the there not a problem that I can'tuse
I can do it the mix hi
hi
hiop Hipop hip hop
[Musique]
encore du double platine pour la rap
machine c'était sugar gang dernière
danse après Diosa combass et kissing
figuration libre suite voici François
Boiron ou on est son disons plus tard
interview pinceau du maestro qui parle
du cinéma de son papa et de la
télévision repinte façon